[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien sûr pas trop vos questions le
comptoir
[Musique]
non je crois pas justement je pense que
le tribunal médiatique vient souvent se
substituer à la justice et que ça peut
être très dangereux et que effectivement
ce qu'a révélé le mouvement mis tous et
qu'il y avait peut-être un des vôtres
justice concernant les plaintes pour
viol et agression sexuelle
et c est ça qui peut contribuer à
résoudre mais que la justice ne passera
certainement pas par le tribunal banias
tic si même une antithèse de la justice
alors moi je suis à fond pour le vaccin
si on offre un vaccin j'y vais ce un
problème parce vaccinale aussi donc
conditionné l'accès à certains endroits
au vaccin
je suis pas favorable parce que je pense
qu'on a dit qu'une partie de nos
libertés et on ne sait pas où ça peut
s'arrêter et je pense que ça a
d'ailleurs un caractère contre-productif
parce que si vous rend le vaccin
obligatoire ça va accentuer la défiance
de la population envers le vaccin
oui aux vaccins vont passer l'hiver
[Musique]
question difficile je pense pas mais
j'observe aujourd'hui
récemment les néo féministes etc de
mimer leurs aînés en faisant un nouveau
manifeste des 343 ou demandant un
allongement du délai bvg et je trouve
que c'est assez symptomatique du cdp
ministres d'ailleurs qui minent le
combat de ces aînés que de voir
véritablement les problèmes qui se
posent aux femmes dans la société
aujourd'hui dirigeant et mélenchon parce
que je pense que l'extérieur petit trait
pour coup on est très intéressant c'est
qu'il y aurait plein de choses à venir
et en plus j'aime bien j'admire sa
culture politique mais je pense que
vraiment qu'on sera c'est drôle aussi
[Musique]